hey everybody welcome back to park tech
and today we are tackling technopolis
and the description of this scenario
states that in the middle of the
bustling metropolis of tokyo you've
acquired a shopping mall encompassing a
full city block you are to develop it
into a thriving aura entertainment
complex with the addition of theme park
attractions but with nowhere else to go
you'll have to build it on the roofs of
the existing buildings and the scenario
goals are to have a cleanliness rating
of at least 90 percent
this one's a little bit of a joke
honestly but still quite the challenge
and we also have to get 450 guests in
the park so let's take a look and see
what this park is actually like
never mind the continue button that was
one of my old testing saves
and some of the very observant viewers
and theme park enthusiasts watching
might already recognize what this
scenario is based on it's inspired by
tokyo
dome city also known as la cua which is
a theme park in the middle of tokyo
featuring thunder dolphin actually is it
steel yeah it's thunder dolphin uh i
always mix those two up but yeah it's a
really cool intimate hyper coaster in
the middle of tokyo and that's built on
the roofs and even through some
buildings and that's generally what this
scenario is inspired by and also just
like highway hijinx we get some traffic
passing through as well so that's really
fun
but yeah this is uh our map for today
it's just the roofs of these buildings
and some fun facts that i might as well
say about this scenario because there
are some fun easter eggs in here most of
the logos that you see on these roofs
are actually inspired by real life
companies
this one's very similar to the tobu
brand of shopping malls and also train
lines this one's i believe inspired by
109 at shibuya
this one's a little bit like eon
the the design of the store is also a
little bit like the eon stores in japan
this building i imagine could be
somewhat similar to daiso which is a 100
yen store and this building which has a
stall in it actually is
kind of like a donkey quixote now none
of these are exactly the same they're
all a little bit inspired but not quite
their real thing
but that's uh that's what these stores
are inspired by anyway also the name of
this map is based on one of my personal
favorite songs technopolis by yellow
magic orchestra which is a really cool
japanese synth pop band from the 70s and
80s who are kind of ahead of the game
it's kind of from craftwork times anyway
let's get back into the park
side of things
all we have to work with at least for
the start of the scenario are the
floorless coaster the hydraulically
launched coaster and the vertical
spinning coaster and some flat rides but
not nearly enough to get 450 guests into
this park so
that's gonna be quite the challenge
especially to try and fit in everything
in this very tight space
so without further ado let's give it a
shot
all right so before i go on in this
commentary i just want to quickly
apologize for some of the audio clipping
in that first little tidbit of this
video
for some reason sometimes my microphone
sets its audio level way too high
without me changing anything about it
it's been like this for years and i
still don't know how to change it and i
feel like i've tried everything i could
but um yeah that's beside the point next
time i'm gonna check my levels again
before i record because there was a bit
of clipping going on here and there also
i fact checked myself and laqua is not
exactly tokyo dom city tokyo dom city
comprises of a bunch of different
attractions around the tokyo dome the
tokyo dome being this giant indoor
baseball stadium in the middle of tokyo
technically inside bunkyo city which is
one of the special wards of tokyo and
i'm going way off topic here but tokyo
is technically a region made up of many
different special wards that are
basically
municipalities of their own so you have
shinjuku which is the big downtown area
you've got shibuya which is where the
big crossing is you've got ikebukuro
which is another place
which has like riku university and it
has a lot of
weep culture going on there but that's
all beside the point bunkier city is one
of these special wards it is tokyo dome
inside of it and the tokyo dome has a
bunch of things around it which
collectively are called tokyo dome city
one of these things is lakwa but to be
honest when it comes to especially
amusement parks lakwa is definitely the
most interesting thing about tokyo dome
city it actually has a few theme park
rides outside of that area as well just
across the road from lakwa but like what
i think is the most
recognizable and picturesque part of the
whole complex and it's where thunder
dolphin is and that giant hopless ferris
wheel which is all the reasons that i
want to go
to tokyodom city usually anyway um so
this scenario is really inspired by
lakwa and to start off with a good
roller coaster because well it's both
fun to build a roller coaster but it's
also a necessary money maker i figured i
might as well go for something that's
very similar to the coaster type that
steel uh that thunder dolphin is i i
already said i keep mixing these up
steel dolphin is a roller coaster in
china also made by intamin but thunder
dolphin is an intimate hyper coaster
that's built basically on top of la qua
it goes through a building it goes
through a helpless ferris wheel it
offers some of the best views of tokyo
which is
insane that you can get them from a
roller coaster it's not really the best
intamin hyper coaster i've ever been on
but i think it's very underrated i think
it's setting in the middle of tokyo with
arguably the best view i've ever had on
a roller coaster makes it so much more
of an interesting experience and what
other rollercoaster goes on top of and
through buildings i mean
that's just absolutely insane so
this little coaster that i built here is
at least a tiny bit inspired by
thunderdolphin i figured i wouldn't
really have the space to build a lift
hill and let this layout go all around
the perimeter of the park as
thunderdolphin does in real life
so instead i made it into a quick
launched coaster which allows it to have
a very very narrow footprint it really
only uses you know half of the park's
parameter and then only just two tiles
because it's just using those immoments
and dive loops to get around so you can
see you have a very simple bunch of
elements but i think it still has a
decent ride time certainly a little bit
more than some intamin uh launched
coasters do and you still get a bunch of
good elements mixed in there some air
time some good hang time as well i think
and hopefully although of course i can't
account for the actual experience on the
ride is going to be a good launch as
well
so that's the first ride and then
combined into the station of this
intimate launch coaster i decided to
build a scrambled eggs
just because it's always hard to come up
with flat rides that are good to build
in scenarios like these because when
space is very limited i think it's
probably a good idea to stay away from
some of the bigger flat rides and
scrambled eggs has one of the smallest
footprints you can get for a ride of its
kind so it's really good to just get
some of those simple carousels out there
and not have to waste too much space of
my park already and then as for the
general architectural style of this park
i decided to keep it very minimalistic
very futuristic and it's not quite
sci-fi because there's not a lot of
piping or things like that going on but
it's definitely inspired by sci-fi
aesthetic i decided to use a lot of
simple art shapes and very simple colors
mostly gray scales and then use art
shapes to add some
blotches of color here and there is some
highlights in a very particular color
scheme so
so far i'm sticking with that dark
purple-ish color but adding to that i'm
going to add some
red maroon kind of colors some some
oranges some yellows a little bit of
green but all kind of in the same
ballpark no very washed out colors
they're all going to be pretty bright
and they're all going to be used very
sparingly just to add some some accented
details everywhere in the environment
that's otherwise going to be very
minimalistic and very grayscale-ish
now
this plaza here i really couldn't figure
out what to do with it exactly but
because this is such a crammed park and
because space is
well uh lacking mostly i decided i
wanted to get a very big plaza in the
middle of this park without anything in
the middle of it because i think parks
like this could tend to become very
crammed very quickly if you just built
rides everywhere and i think that the
balance is in giving guests enough open
space as well especially when there's
not
many parts that they can walk on
otherwise the paths would just become
way too crowded so this is kind of
a way to disperse the crowds a little
bit through uh this space it's also
inspired by some of the logos of the
special wards of tokyo
and really the prefectures of japan as
well one of the things i've always loved
about the city is that every ward has
its own logo and all of them have a very
similar style
cities and municipalities are infamous
for having horrible logos and flags and
there's this really interesting uh talk
on this by roman mars it's uh one of my
favorite ted talks
about flag design and the different
wards of tokyo actually have really cool
flags and they all fit the same kind of
style they're all quite symmetrical very
much focused on the center of the
picture and they all consist of mostly
just two colors a white background or
something else and a very symmetrical um
shape in the middle of it which usually
radiates out from the middle so it was
inspired by that kind of aesthetic that
i decided to make that weird uh kind of
sci-fi looking pattern in the uh in the
plaza there
also
i had no idea how to make that plaza
look interesting without placing
anything in the middle because i just
wanted to have you know as much open
space as i could to have the guests the
spurs
and after that i decided you know might
as well add some symmetry and add a flat
right right next to this plaza
which is one tile less wide than the
plaza itself so you know it's not
exactly symmetrical but i don't really
mind and i think especially given the
fact that park attacks has an isometric
perspective and the weight of everything
that's right next to this flat ride you
don't really notice it so bad what you
do notice horribly though is what
happened just there whenever the flat
right does its thing it just goes uh
straight through the walls
uh don't worry about it that's something
i'm gonna try to fix later on but for
now it does look a little bit goofy i
will have to admit that
um but yeah that's just something that
ended up happening whenever this ride
starts spinning i always forget that
when this ride gets going it kind of
goes to the side because intuitively it
kind of feels like it just sticks to the
middle there and doesn't really move
from it uh but yeah in reality it's kind
of on an arm that goes diagonal in a
similar way as an enterprise does just
not quite as far and starts moving like
that which is interesting because i
think this flat ride is kind of a
modernized version of a very very old
flat ride one of the
classics when flat rides were still made
out of wood was a very very similar kind
of thing it just wouldn't go up as much
and it wouldn't tilt as much
and be generally as intense but you know
flat rise getting more and more intense
over time
is something that's very noticeable if
you look back on some of the past
versions of flat rides that we have
these days
now as for the goals of this scenario
i think getting to 450 guests is not
really going to be the challenge
generally if you build a few coasters
and you have enough flat rides and your
park rating is good enough you'll
definitely get there eventually what i
did recognize while playing this
scenario is that getting to a
cleanliness rating of 90 percent
especially on such a tight space is
actually a lot more difficult than i
expected and that turned out to be
really the the challenge of this park
so
really all i can do at this point is
hire as many janitors as possible but at
some point i realized that that wasn't
quite doing the trick so in the near
future i'm definitely gonna have to
build some kind of staff facility and a
training center to help them to keep the
park more clean especially with how
crowded it's going to get
i mean
450 people in parchitect scale
on the roof of one shopping mall that's
definitely kind of pushing it but you
know we'll get there eventually i'm
pretty sure it'll work out
now as for working out
i decided to build a coaster in this
very tiny amount of space and i really
wanted it to be a coaster with a lift
hill and just a
nice long layout lots of inversions and
lots of stuff going on just so then it
wouldn't be you know an obvious cop-out
just to to make it fit into this tiny
park i really wanted to have something
with a good layout and and some good
stuff in it
and that turned out to be quite a
challenge especially because i you know
also just wanted to build a realistic
layout nothing that would seem too out
of the ordinary for roller coasters
eventually i settled on a b m floor list
where we start off with that implement
go into
a bizarre contraption
of a
dive loop cobra roll kind of going into
itself
thing
after that it kind of meanders around
and tries to make some curves to get
back to the station while not wasting
too much space and then we transition
into a zero g roll which
goes back to one curve into a break run
where realistically i think would be the
the transfer track uh which leaves
enough space for a flat ride a q line
and whatever else i would need for this
station on this plateau here so all in
all i am pretty happy with how this
layout turned out and to be very honest
this recording that you're watching
right now
was not my first attempt at this layout
i spent way too long trying to figure
this thing out and eventually ended up
with this mess decided to just redo the
recording once i knew where the layout
was generally gonna go and then uh did
some
adjustments afterwards as you can see
there made the zero g roll very flat to
the point where it's kind of more like a
barrel roll really
or something in between
just to make sure that the speed is
right and by the time it hits the brake
run
it's mostly slowed down which i'm very
happy with it's always so satisfying to
have a coaster which rolls into the
brakes with not much energy left in it
so you don't have to waste too much of
that potential energy that it builds up
on the lift hill that's just always one
of the things that i aim for whenever
i'm building layouts and it's really
only possible when you're building a
coaster that's not on flat ground and
where you can use elevation differences
to your advantage so
that's also why i decided to build this
station on the highest part of the map
and raise it up a little bit more
just to make sure that we can have a
high brake run and station building
so yeah right next to it i ended up
building the uh orbiter flat ride you
may also notice that i removed the side
of the riptide so that it doesn't crash
into the wall anymore
and honestly i actually kind of prefer
it this way it's not as symmetrical
anymore it's not as predictable of a
scenery anymore
so yeah i'm pretty happy with how that
turned out
i decided to redo the final curve into
the break run just a little bit more so
the curve goes up and then you fall down
into the brakes give the zero g roll a
little bit more of its zero g rollness
back uh to also allow the coaster train
to be a bit slower once it hits the zero
g roll and really get the most out of
the hang time that you want to get in
there and then it's just a complicated
patchwork of q lines and exit paths just
to get everybody into the coaster and
the flat ride and also the extra flat
right that i built on the side here
so that's the puzzle for the coaster
itself i decided to give it a kind of
interesting color scheme where it
transitions from different shades of
blue throughout the layout which
i think especially for this park given
that it only has two coasters and
there's no space to build anything else
at this point it's a nice touch as well
because it means that i can play with
different
you know trek ski trek color schemes
despite the fact that there's only two
coasters so it kind of looks like
there's more going on than there really
is and you really get that whole
spectrum from a kind of very light
greenish blue to very dark indigo-ish
colors so it's it's it's nice to have
all those different colors on the layout
i think
um but yeah that's that puzzle done and
at this point i had to figure out how to
do the scenery because honestly in this
scenario scenery kind of came after the
fact my first
you know problem was trying to fix where
everything went trying to put all of the
pieces together and then just figure out
afterwards what i can do with the
scenery so for the coaster here i
decided it would probably just make most
sense if the coaster station building is
the thing that sticks out the most the
the tallest part of this whole build
but it would be nice to include
everything around it into the same kind
of building so i'm keeping the station
itself very simple here just a simple
rectangular box which is
usually something that i try to tell
people not to do with your stations
because it's pretty predictable
but in this case i think the the real
interesting part of this whole build is
going to come from ending all of the
things around it and making this coaster
seem like it's just going into this
giant complex of buildings where you
can't tell where the building ends and
begins and it's all just kind of snaking
together at least that was the whole
idea behind it
this is also where you really see the
theme emerging of gray and lightish gray
walls and roofs and then using large
white cubes to
make all of the cornices i suppose for
lack of a better word for some of these
these sides and
beside the roofs and beside the walls to
kind of accent the ends of them and then
on top of those and on and beside the
walls i'm adding the colored accents as
well using the even smaller cubes now
for some of the people watching this and
wondering you know ex what kind of
strategy was behind this exactly
usually i would take the cubes that you
see on the side here and make them
really small so
0.13
for some of the accented details and at
that point you have to press alt 8 to
make the the smallest grid that you can
with an even number of grid pieces just
so that all of these tiny cubes connect
and you can make these large colored
lines with them
and for the whites
large cornice pieces i put the cubes on
0.25 size and the grid on uh the fourth
size so odds and four and then you can
perfectly put them on the grid as well
as three pieces behind each grid piece
and it's really nice to add different
details it also kind of gives me some
art deco vibes especially what i'm doing
with it here kind of like streamline
modern except there's no round parts
like you usually find in those kinds of
art deco builds because it's very hard
to make things properly round in this
game especially if you're working with
the art pieces but yeah the overall
aesthetic is definitely inspired a
little bit by art deco as well and it's
it's funny honestly i've been teasing
art deco for
so many episodes at this point i think
going all the way back to the first
episode of a taste of adventure art deco
is very much inspired by
native american architecture like mayan
architecture and the like and it
definitely also already started actually
in disaster peaks i remember now and at
this point i've been doing it kind of in
this episode as well
and
gosh i think even in the last episode i
came back to it as well yeah definitely
with the the similar
american uh mayan aesthetic so at some
point in the future i'm definitely gonna
have to do full on art deco that day
just hasn't quite arrived yet but i do
find that you know generally art deco
inspired things
uh are also very nice to look at usually
as well there are some art deco inspired
brutalism for instance there's radio
kodvak in the netherlands which i
recently came across again and even
though it's technically a brutalist
building it's made out of raw exposed
concrete you can see the art deco
inspirations in it and i think that's a
huge part of what makes the building so
popular
anyway this is where we start seeing the
snaking paths and roof structures and we
really start seeing how the station
building is part of a larger complex
also with those cornice details on the
uh the square above the flat right there
kind of reflecting what the details in
the big plaza look like and also once
again being kind of
a part of the symmetry along with the
riptide flat ride on the other side i
think this is also where you really see
the color scheme of the park coming out
because once you you notice it um you'll
see that i'm using the same exact color
in different parts of the park so it'll
all come back in different parts i'm
just kind of viewing this whole park as
one big painting and sticking with one
color scheme one mix of colors here and
putting them wherever it feels like it's
in balance looking from above
and then the final flat ride that i've
placed is uh the tourbillon over there
which
i just had to put in this park even
though it's one of the larger flat rides
and it's taking up a lot of space in the
park i felt like it's just
too good of a fit of the general
robotics themed and and technopolis
vibes of this park to not put it in here
so i put that in there as well and then
for the
well i guess this is the staircase
building this is really where people
have to go
up to even get to the coaster and the
flat ride up there i decided to keep
this thing very simple and not put too
much you know uh emphasis on it it's
really just some corrugated metal walls
realistically
but i think it works well enough in its
context and i think that's a large part
of looking at everything in its context
especially in parkitect where you can
never look at one building at a time
you'll always see at least some of the
environments because of the isometric
perspective
oh and something i haven't really talked
about but i put some
horizontal grit pattern of cornices
underneath the roller coaster here to
kind of make it seem like
it's been built as a transportable
coaster the thing is usually coaster
supports i have footers going into the
ground and quite deep actually to anchor
them and into the ground but given the
fact that this is built on top of a
building i think that wouldn't be really
realistic so realistically i figured
this coaster would have supports more
like a transportable coaster or a
fairground coaster where the supports
connect to
a network of horizontal beams on the
floor and correct me if i'm wrong here
because there aren't many roller
coasters built on the roofs of buildings
so i'm not exactly sure whether this
holds true but i
definitely think this would be the case
for any roller coaster built on top of a
building uh in real life um i think it's
the case for thunder dolphin if i
remember correctly and looking at povs
as well
so
also speaking of thunderdolphin this
little element at the end of the the
first rollercoaster is a little bit
inspired by the way thunderdolphin
glides on its rooftop you also have all
of these horizontal bars and i think it
looks really cool and for a while i
couldn't really come up with a way to
decorate this part of the coaster so
eventually i ended up going for this and
i think it was a nice touch to add
and finally
we come to some of the last spots that
we still need to fill on the map at this
point i was almost at 450 guests as you
can tell by the bottom left corner there
but i still wasn't hitting that 90
cleanliness rating so i figured i'm
really gonna have to build a staff room
and a training center also i feel like a
horrible boss for doing this because i
still haven't done it and i keep
forgetting about my stuff every single
time i start a park
don't be like me honestly i i think i'd
be a very terrible businessman
but yeah eventually i
ended up deciding that i had to place
this here i think it's much better than
adding another flat ride in
and for this building i'm generally
experimenting a little bit but then
undoing some of the experimentation as
well i figured for a while i could try
something else but given the fact that
everything in this park is so coherent
and everything kind of resembles each
other and references each other i think
it only makes sense to make this
building look a lot like the other
buildings in the area so once again
going with the same cube aesthetic
taking the roofs from another building
and trying as much as possible to make
this thing connect to the surrounding
environment as well and also add a
little bit of greenery at the end here
because well putting trees on rooftops
is one of my favorite things to do and
in general
honestly the very idea of this park is
something that i'm really behind and
that is that there are too many roofs in
this world that are completely unused
especially flat roofs that are really
only used for hvac systems and stuff
like that it's such a waste there's so
much awesome stuff that could be done
with roofs
whether it be putting restaurants on top
of them urban gardens all of that sort
of stuff you always have amazing views
from roofs roofs are some of the best
part of any building and they're too
often way too underused and this is
something that we can't always help for
one uh roofs have to
keep themselves up in the air and
sometimes it's very hard to build on
roofs because of structural integrity
one example that comes to mind is that
there's actually a don quixote store in
tokyo which has an intimate half-pipe
coaster on the roof
but it's never opened and the story is
supposedly that it's just structural
integrity it wouldn't be able to
withstand the lateral g-forces another
story is that there were noise
complaints from surrounding inhabitants
nobody knows exactly which story is
correct but anyway uh that's the sort of
stuff that we need more of in this world
and it's not always easy to get there
but you know this scenario is kind of an
attempt to dream of a better world i
suppose
anyway that's it for this playthrough
let's see how it turned out
so
there we go that's 90 cleanliness and
guests in the park
and
let's just have a quick overview of what
the park actually looks like for once in
my life i can do it in a single
screenshot which is
very funny but um
now let's actually do a quick pov of all
of the coasters as well so first off we
have the hydraulically launched coaster
which is in this station right now so
that
we should be good to go let me see if
anything's actually happening
all right
we're going
so because this is a hydraulic launch of
course we get to hook up to the launch
first and there we go
hydraulic launches are just some of the
best launches definitely coming from
intamin i'm a huge fan of these so yeah
we definitely get some nice air time
there then into a zero g roll and then
finally an immelmann turn to turn back
to another airtime hill
and finally into the station so
really it is a pretty short ride to be
honest
uh just an imminent into an air time
into zero zero immediate air time so not
too much is going on but i really had
quite a tight space to work with here
and i think
given just how little space it takes up
in the park especially because it's kind
of toward the edges on space that you
know it's not really using anything that
could be used very differently
i think it's a it's a very nice
compromise to get a launched coaster in
here with still some decent elements
and a decent mix and variety of elements
as well so that's the launched coaster
now for the b m floorless i think i'm
just gonna
let this one go back to the station and
see if we can catch the next ride when
it's actually fixed well let's see if
we've got any
uh mechanics coming up to this one all
right so there's our mechanic he's just
gonna have to go through the staircase
in the middle of the building here and
then we can actually follow the path as
it goes up to the coaster so there's a
little bit of uh going around there then
into the uh exit there which is this
whole covert section here and then
hopefully the people can get on and we
can get on and we can do a quick pov of
this ride so
we've really got this interesting setup
here with all of the different parts
going over and under each other and kind
of intertwining here it's very hard to
tell what's going on
unless you turn on the buildings which
i'll do in a second but yeah first
a pov of this coaster
given how tight this thing is it kind of
reminds me of daymonen at tivoli which
is
a layout which i find really impressive
especially given the fact that it's real
life you know but this one is a little
bit crazier we start off going into that
immelmann then into kind of bizarre
elements into a cobra roll
it's really weird but it just works on a
very tight space and you know we already
have four inversions going into this
very compact layout then some turns
going around which is kind of typical i
suppose for the latter half of a b m
coaster into this zero g raw
barrel roll kind of thing it really does
have some interaction with the path here
a bit of a literal head chopper at the
end there and some of the buildings that
could presumably be you know the
transfer track and all of that jazz but
i decided to you know pass on that one
but there's still some interesting stuff
going on here if we turn off the
buildings you can see some of the part
work that's actually in here this giant
kind of staircase and then the
intermingling paths here with over here
the uh pretty large
uh q line for the orbiter which is also
a very popular ride i'm kind of blown
away just by how popular this thing is
uh but let's turn the buildings back on
that definitely looks a bit better
and over here we have the
still turned off right
uh that's such a classic why do i always
always make that mistake with at least
one of my flat rides in my park
i just realized i basically could have
done without this thing because i've
reached the goals anyway but it just it
just looks too good on that position and
it just looks too good as a flat ride in
general
i don't know why everything is breaking
down but we'll continue the tour so we
have the tool beyond here
doing its thing looking absolutely nuts
i
really want to write one of these things
even though i've heard they're not quite
as interesting to ride as they are to
look at i think they're definitely one
of the most interesting and creative
flat right designs in real life then
we've got the jumper here and the food
stuffs i couldn't really come up with a
better name for some of the food stuff
it's not very good food stuffs by the
way i decided to go with some bubble tea
because we are in an asian map after all
and bubble tea is from taiwan if i
remember correctly but
the general culture plus you can
definitely find it in tokyo as well
and then we have a vending machine for
food which might be the reason that
my hunger rating is not quite that good
definitely something to keep in mind
once you get one of these scenarios
where you start off without a proper
food stall you can use the vending
machine chips to have people stave off
the hunger for the most part but
obviously it's not very healthy with all
of that salt and sunflower oil but you
know it's uh
whoops it's it's something that that
kind of works in a pinch i suppose but
next time i should definitely research a
proper food stall as well here we have
the riptide no longer smashing speakers
heads into the ceiling so that's nice
and
another flat ride hidden in here and in
here as well so all things considered i
think there's a lot of stuff going on in
this map but just enough not to make it
feel too crammed and definitely once you
turn off the scenery you can tell how
everything actually works and you can
see that there's a lot of path space
just kind of hidden everywhere just to
make sure that this park doesn't get too
crammed despite the fact that the
footprint that we have to work with is
very small in this one
oh and before i forget i do usually want
to try to cover the ratings but i always
forget to do this but the ratings on the
coasters are pretty good we've got 82
excitement and extreme excitement on
this one and decently medium intensity
and nausea and on this one it's just
very high so not quite as good it's not
quite as intense um but still i think a
decent amount of variety had i a little
bit more space i definitely would have
included a junior coaster as well but
it's really hard to make those things
actually fit into a compact space
ironically enough i think it's easier to
build a little bit larger and built a
proper thrill ride which is definitely
best for your money making as well so i
think the general gameplay strategy you
know looking uh
besides just aesthetics is is definitely
followed here
all right stuff keeps breaking down i
don't know why it's the heartbreaker
especially that's just always doing this
anyway let's get out of here well
actually
i might save very quickly hold on so
this is actually my third attempt as you
can tell let's get out of here and see
what kind of trophy we get from this map
i'm actually not sure
alright so we just got one of the
buildings that's on the map beside our
park
fair enough i think that works and it
kind of finishes off this little island
in space
and then we move to the next scenario
which is
oh man this is going to be a good one
it's dragon valley
so
as you may be able to tell from this
island that you get and the preview shot
dragon valley is going to have some very
difficult terrain to work with so that's
going to be very interesting but that's
all for the next episode thanks for
watching everybody and i'll see you next
time